俺思ったんだ
とって
卵を何個食えるのかなって言っ
こっち外れる音が入っちゃった夏です立海食べてみよう
卵生卵ですよ卵ってのが1日1個がいいっていう説がありませんまあ球を栄養めっちゃ
あるから栄養を摂りすぎもよくないみたいなやつですよねそれぞれって言うんですけど
で実際人って生きてるうちに卵めっちゃ食ってるんですよ1日のうちにこうみて
くださいゴムの切手を
price 屋さんがあるんですけどもそのオムライス屋さんの l サイズ
なんと卵6個使われておりますあります
すごいお店で1個食べるときにロッコ君だった
もう勝負1日何個来ても問題ないんじゃないかみたいな計算すぎが成り立っておりまし
て確かに1個より多くはもう一緒みたい
全然一緒です持ってなると人って何個卵を食えるのかなってやったそのお腹が満腹的な
bot 栄養さ的な限界とも素敵に飽きるとか飽きないとかいろんな限界の要素がある
中で
人は何かけるなって言うんですとやってみようと思います
なぜさんがうん俺が産後でだ湖水ので一般男性も生卵をただ単にを割って食べるんです
からそれぞれそんな気になるの始めたんだけど
あっはぁまずは一般なんての広げですはい
この口に出すんですよねそうですね
まず1個目ですねー
[音楽]
笑ってますねー
いっていい自分がこれ頭を打ったらやべーなと
ああああ動画いい顔するねこれでしたはい
ウェイナー各党がぐらいですかやらん ok をこれ
花井ペースが速いったんですよ4年生卵の栄養を調べてんだこれ本当にやる意味あるの
かなって
やり始めてから調べなきゃいけません
フェイスゲイ脳や細胞膜の修復と構成をしてくれるらしいです
あとね記憶力や脳の成長を促せですね
認知症の改善に効果があるいやっああっ後中性脂肪を下げてくれるらしいです
高血圧予防にもなり待ってねちーじゃないですか
あとここでグイーン入りました大田
案外大丈夫が
ここマネーじゃじゃーんここでさあどうでした
どうでした
大歯では人がやることじゃねそういうのを解決しきっているのはまた我々の仕事です
から
確かにまぁだいたいダム僕ぐらいくれたらいいほうなんじゃないかなとはいとても送っ
てみようと思いますはい
いただきます
にこえす
以後へすごくあふれ s go ない
サボヤッホー
[音楽]
4小屋見てらんねー
って返したなんだかねうんからくるこの謎の米
[音楽]
覚えたいん
7これはい
[音楽]
いやースゲーよ8声
売ってくれうどうぞ
[音楽]
机入っ
あーん
car
うううう
ni
car
me
あっはぁ
もうついけると思ったんだけどデブな体がちょっと嫌がりますね
あまだまたカッコイッてパパデモス後栄養素はいいんですけどワイプ食べ過ぎは良く
ないんでバランスよく
からもっと皆さん余っちゃったね煽っちゃった畑のみんなー